well let's talk should we start with
kind of the big Davos picture because
everyone comes to get a sense of you
know where the world is right now and
and I guess starting with the economics
threats of recession concerns about
Divergent parts for globalization or
whatever whatever you want to call it I
mean where do you see it right now I
don't think we're in quite the negative
space
which says that two-thirds of economists
are predicting a global recession next
year that seems a little on the dark
side to me because the news out of the
US tends to point towards a soft Landing
the news out of Europe doesn't point to
a disaster anymore which is what we were
anticipating for this time of year every
German's running out of gas hibernating
German industry and China is is a
disaster in many ways and I think a real
Menace for Global Public Health but as
far as the economy is concerned it's the
end of zero covid so the breaks are off
and we would expect a major rebound next
year but those three together and you've
got 60 of the global economy and it's
not heading in the downward direction
that we were worried about I think huge
centrifugal forces of a political kind
but um in terms of just the basic growth
Dynamic for trade and investment it's
not as bad as it was looking through a
couple months ago but does it feel as a
you know professor as a historian who
who has specialized in World War One
World War II
those Eerie moments before you know the
the Magic Mountain and and Thomas Mann
and all of that do you are you still
kind of getting those worrying Echoes
now or did is it less now than it was
six months 12 months ago of kind of
World War III I mean the war in Ukraine
feels very close if you're in Central
Europe if you're anywhere you know I was
just in Vienna and that's just it's the
story that dominates everything else
it's on the news every single day this
is the story so in those terms we're
kind of Balkan Wars 1908 1909 we're not
in 1914 moment um because I think the
real fear of atomic escalation has
abated somewhat I think we're beginning
to get a sense of what the Russian
limits are but 2022 was incredibly scary
I mean the Taiwan Straits escalation was
dramatic and I think what's also
striking there is that come the G20
meeting in the autumn what did Biden she
decide to do some serious talking and we
know it's serious because we don't know
anything about what went on and you know
they weren't leaking they weren't
playing it for political points like
they've been doing for the last year or
so so I think that points to a scenario
of not detaunt but I think de-escalation
or at least some Awareness on the part
of the key actors of just how dangerous
the situation was getting and I think
that sense of a reset is palpable it's a
very different mood here from what it
was in May last year I mean Davos in May
last year was a campaigning site for the
Ukraine and Poland the whole thing was
taken over by an anti-russian
campaigning mood doesn't seem to have
that kind of vibe this time around and
you mentioned China a second ago in
public health
it is it is strange isn't it I mean you
know the numbers to the extent that we
know the numbers in China are pretty
extraordinary and yet
it's not discussed that much here in
Davos at least I think it may be the
most rapidly spreading epidemic in
history because you're talking about 1.4
billion people hidden behind a shield of
zero covid immuno naive suddenly exposed
to Omicron which is super infectious
just ripped through we're talking about
hundreds of millions of infections in a
matter of days and we don't really know
I think what comes out of that yet and I
am seriously concerned for this year
that we are basically complacent about
the pandemic story not just the China
aspect but the this but the new variants
coming out of the US which overwhelm but
apparently all our existing immunity now
we was bored as we could possibly be
with the pandemic story no one wants to
go there and I think that's a big driver
of the kind of denial that we're in plus
the reality in the west as we know is
one in which the normal life is returned
but if there's one thing that could
really blow up our expectations of a
good 2023 or at least a relatively less
bad 2023 it would be a bad highly
infectious Delta lethality kind of
variant coming from somewhere and that
would that would stop the show as we
know that that causes a huge downturn in
the global economy so it hasn't gone
away I I'm afraid it hasn't it seems
well it's back I mean it's coming at us
faster than ever before arguably we are
just I think gambling that the
resistance that we have already built up
through multiple exposures is going to
see us through it may we simply don't
know but that contingency that sense of
uncertainty itself is hard to keep
focused on because it's so disconcerting
I mean does it really mean that our
summer holiday plans are contingent on
bad medical news again but I think a
realistic assessment of the situation
says yes they may be because I mean
final thing I mean Davos you've been to
a few DeVos is now
I mean how do first of all how does this
feel kind of in comparison with others
but also
it's does this still play a useful role
as far as you can tell in in in the
world what's really striking to me is
the shifting balance between the
different players here I was speaking to
some Indians who were here and there's a
huge Indian Presence at Davos in the
same way as the Indians were key to the
G20 meeting in the Autumn anchoring
really the compromise that was made that
that allowed the resolution on Russia
the Indians are a vast presence here but
what they notice is that everyone else
is missing so the Indians will tell you
that we rule the roost but where are the
G7 the only Western leader that's coming
is solav Schultz of Germany and so
there's a weird sense in that they've
inherited the Davos mantle at a moment
when the old backers of the old Davos
the flat world full globalization she is
the champion of the rules of the role
you know back in 2017 that world that
seems to have gone
strange isn't it it's kind of yeah well
anyway Adam too thank you very much for
talking to us pleasure thanks for having
me on